moi ça m'arrache la case des tout-petits
de prendre des décisions la de fermer
des salles de spectacles des théâtres
mais on n'a pas le choix faut réduire
les contacts sociaux une question de vie
ou de mort lorraine pintal et directrice
artistique et générale du théâtre du
nouveau monde bonsoir bonsoir
qu'est-ce que vous passez donc de ce
soutien qui est annoncée aujourd'hui
c'est un soutien qu'on attendait depuis
des mois bien sûr ça vient après une
nouvelle qui nous a tous un peu frappé
de plein fouet c'est à dire cette
fermeture au mois d'octobre et je
comprends très bien que c'est des
raisons difficiles qui motive ce genre
de décision maintenant il fallait
qu'elle mesures qui sont annoncées et
plusieurs millions d'ajouter au milieu
des arts la culture et entre autres les
arts de la scène parce que les arts de
la scène
c'est beaucoup de monde beaucoup
d'artistes beaucoup d'artisans des
directions théâtre et c'est à n'y fit
longtemps d'avancé alors la
revendication que nous faisions avec le
conseil québécois du théâtre c'était
justement cette compensation du billets
invendus
parce qu'on visait avec 20 %
d'occupation de salles depuis la
réouverture en septembre alors qu'on
était de jouer devant 80 85 % de cinq
ans alors ça leur 75% des revenus de
billetterie est ce que ça vous convient
ça et six mois un programme de six mois
est ce que c'est la bonne chose aussi à
faire mais je dois dire que le six mois
mois ravi parce que ma part c'était que
ce soit une aide à court terme
uniquement pour le mois d'octobre nos
salles sont fermées
quand on parle de six mois jusqu'en mars
c'est que ça permet aux directions de
théâtre aux salles de spectacles de
planifier un peu plus à moyen terme
parce que c'est ce qui arrive
des artistes qui sont engagés jusqu'en
mai juin 2021
quand on leur coupe les vivres du jour
au lendemain on peut pas assurer que la
création se rendent aux spectateurs
alors ceci moi là il est bénéfique c'est
clair maintenant le 75% peut représenter
des bonnes sommes ça dépend évidemment
de la réalité de chaque salle de
spectacle mais c'est évident que ça nous
de l'oxygène on respire lieu en sachant
qu'on ne s'en va pas vers un déficit
assuré qu'ils auraient pu compromettre
la création et la vitalité de nos
institutions
et alors je salue cette décision de
notre ministre de la culture et de
monsieur legault parce que huit les
côtes depuis la fermeture des salles
lundi dernier il ya eu des réunions
d'urgence et on a revendiqué à nouveau
l'importance de cette assurance billets
dont on va profiter j'en suis certaine
ainsi le magma québec dit que ce sont
les diffuseurs et les producteurs qui
vont s'assurer que les artistes et les
autres employés les auteurs les
traducteurs les compositeurs les
metteurs en scène les techniciens
impliqué dans le spectacle soit compensé
a même l'aide financière qu'ils étaient
octroyés comment vous allez faire ça en
28 ans veut respecter les contrats qu'on
avait signé avec ses acteurs et ses
artisans et ses artistes à dire que
contrairement à cet automne où on a fait
des programmations adapté avec moi
demande sur scène des plus petites
productions moins de gens engagés est
longue les moyens de compenser justement
pour les contrats qui ont été
malheureusement annulé ou reporté et ça
va être notre responsabilité mais c'est
ce qu'on veut faire c'est profiter de
ses revenus que qu'on ne soupçonnait
plus et qui vont nous permettre
justement de payer des contrats des
acteurs presque à 100% c'est ce qu'on
souhaite l'envoyons voir ce que ça veut
dire qu'en montant d'argent de 75% et la
volonté est là parce que l'aide de
réduire directement aux artistes mais
moi j'ai comme la paix c'est lui par
exemple qui était une initiative du
gouvernement fédéral qui était une
heureuse initiative pour les artistes
travailleurs que tu rêves autonome mais
je crois que les salles de spectacle et
les théâtres et les lieux de diffusion
en fait c'est nous qui sont les
employeurs alors on est les mieux
classés pour pouvoir redonner à
l'artiste le contrat qui malheureusement
dû être annulés est ce que d'autres
moyens pour que l'artiste touche
directement
un montant qui va l'aider à rencontrer
ses fins de mois
peut-être mais celui est un excellent
moyen je peux vous assurer qu'on va le
faire c'est notre intention est celle
orge gouvernement à une écoute par
rapport à nos demandes
et l'oeil à cette aide là aujourd'hui
pour pour les diffuseurs comme vous et
pour les arts de la scène il ya la
subvention salariale qui existe toujours
oui il ya l'aide de monsieur fait geben
également s comprend tout ça monsieur
qu'est ce qu'elle va écouter jean
connaît moins les tournants et
aboutissant alors nous du cojep alors j
med et compagnie à but non lucratif
on relève directement du ministère de la
culture alors est ce que ces deux aides
seront compatibles j'en sais pas
davantage mais une chose est certaine ce
qu'on nous offre aujourd'hui ce qu'on
met sur la table ce 75% que représenter
des sommes d'argent indispensable à la
vitalité de notre création et au
maintien des activités sur scène et à la
rencontre évidemment avec le public
très bien merci beaucoup madame pétales
cie courage